salut c'est normal aujourd'hui une
nouvelle vidéo de réponses aux questions
c'est parti tweet avec des moufles
arras est très drôle on sait tous que ça
va faire sa marque et n'importe quoi est
ce parti je suis actuellement en train
de traiter avec des moufles
voilà c'est bon vous êtes content on a
bien rigolé ou pas bah ouais j'ai des
moufles avec des diamants et alors que
tu vas faire bîmes
je vous fais la patate surprise
excellence et des candidats c'est dans
le cul ça parce que moi justement la
puissance montre nous comment tu te
coiffe le matin c'est bon je coiffais
simplement ma meuf et libanais pardon
c'est hyper racistes saluts norman je
suis libanais et je suis de là bas et je
parie que je ne sais pas lire je suis en
cp et je parie que je ne passerais pas
dans cette vidéo massif ou suis pas
totalement
et merci pour tous deux nous suivent
depuis le liban c'est vraiment cool
c'est toujours plaisir d'avoir des
internautes qui regardent mes vidéos
depuis l'étranger fait un canular
téléphonique à un poste youtuber
j'appelle hugo hugo je suis un
psychopathe qui veut te tuer je veux
d'être en fait là ça ne marche pas quoi
haoues ça marche pas est ce que tu
aimerais être unicorn unijambiste avec
la tête du gilbert montagné
[Musique]
e
non tu as tu faire une chaîne d'îles
deming la réponse est non a pour
l'instant ce parfum de chasse de chen
deming
par contre m'a pas empêché de faire
récemment une petite vidéo cool de
gaming avec un vrai pro gamer vraiment
hardcore c'est à dire mon père aime tu
les mangas de quel genre alors je me
suis mis assez tardivement au manga je
me suis mis à un an
et franchement je kiffe franchement les
langages o'keefe pour l'instant c'est
death note l'attaqué des titans tokyo
ghoul et one piece jeunes commencé mais
il ya plus de 700 épisodes
je pense que j'aurai terminé quand
j'aurai 45 ans a été un défi pour toi
c'est me follow avec ses under score
ludivine obasi défis acceptés
oh non j'ai raté le défi était en trop
dur quelle est la taille des thons
concombre ça peut abuser comme question
mais vas-y
moi je joue le jeu on pose une question
je réponds je mesure c'est parti 22 cm
je te jure je perds un mytho 22 cm c'est
la taille de mon concombre excellent
rien ne vaut la puissance d'un [ __ ] de
concombres demande à ton père jacky
tavaux l'amf a connu mais là il faut de
temps raconté la plus grosse bêtise que
tu as fait quand tu étais petit papa ça
toi alors normal quand il a passé son
bac au premier jour de la première
épreuve il est arrivé 30 minutes en
retard donc ils risquaient de rater son
bac
arrêté à voir le proviseur il a supplié
de le faire rentrer quand même dans
l'épreuve
il s'est excusé le proviseur voulait pas
et puis finalement par compassion a
accepté que norman exceptionnellement
puisse intégrer les preuves hellodemain
deuxième épreuve norman arrive trois
piges en retard bah quoi finalement j'ai
quand même eu mon bac avec mention
retard est ce que tu peux mettre une
photo de moi dans ta vidéo stp ps je
m'appelle thomas zitoun merci je ne peux
pas ne pas mettre la faute au soleil
c'est dire qu'il a 12 ans mais il est
déjà dans la vie active cette photo sa
photo pour sa campagne électorale
fais-nous ton interprétation de jean
claude van damme à la john rachid
arrêter les platement merde suis pas
venu en tant que movistar je suis venu
en tant que jean claude jean claude
c'est jean claude van damme
c'est mon prénom tu as compris je suis
venu parler avec le coeur et quand je
vais parler avec le coeur c'est aussi un
peu avec la bouche parce que je parle
pas avec la bouche ça veut dire que mu
et si je suis muet je suis plus une
movistar j'adore la vie a moins de
titres movistar qui tourne dans la
famille besnier un tas compris venu
parler avec mon coeur est au sec mes
oreilles avec mes yeux mes tétons et mes
couilles tu as compris et ses salles
avec mon frère bon on fait le clic
aggravée comment était ton public de
rennes comme ça
[Applaudissements]
sinon combien de temps va durer la
tournée ton spectacle des super cool biz
où je joue plus à paris à partir du 15
octobre 2015
jusqu'à noël et si vous voulez venir me
voir en dehors de paris je reprends ma
tournée à partir de 2016
voilà les places sont déjà dispo que
penses tu des pokémon écoute moi jouer à
pokémon vu que tout petit j'ai joué à
quasiment toutes les cartouches mais je
me dis vu qu'il ya plein d'adultes qui
joue à pokémon prêterait pas une
cartouche pokémon spécial adulte doit
avec des pokémon un peu plus hardcore
lima sperme cocaïne au zèbre pédophile
un iep lhérisson porquet deux buts
toxiques anar temps à couilles travestir
anti ces mouettes tortue violences
conjugales un nom pour la communauté la
communauté de l'anneau
c'est une bonne question c'est que je
n'ai pas la prétention de pouvoir donner
un nom aux gens qui me regardent
alors je pose un petit truc peut-être
que vous pouvez suggérer des
propositions de noms dans les
commentaires et puis mettez vous d'aider
pousse les uns les autres et peut-être
qu'à une proposition qui ressortira du
lot alesi proposer des nombres
communauté on va se marrer allez soyons
fous fous on se lâche un peu
merci d'avoir gardé ma vidéo continue à
vous abonner au max et je vous dis à
bientôt en vidéo ou dans la vraie vie
au fait les meufs de twitter je vous
faut alors évidemment avec plaisir venir
si j'ai le plus grand respect et la
question piège
bon déjà il faut surtout pas être
sincère non franchement wet un peu plus
grosse way ni mitigé pas franchement
c'est pareil je suis aussi grosse que ce
tonneau ouais ni mentir non franchement
que tu es moins grosse moins grosses en
plus tu mens